all right everybody
it is a bonus friday show you know we do
our direct messages tuesday wednesday
thursday yesterday we did two shows
because we also did
a debate recap which about 400 000
of you guys watched you watched me drink
tequila
and and kick my dog under the table uh
msnbc would be thrilled to have those
kind of numbers so thank you guys for
for
watching everything we're doing here a
lot of good stuff is happening and i
think we've carved out a little space
for sane people who want a little bit of
nuance in their news and who don't want
to be hysterical nut bags
so you're amongst the lucky few that see
the world that way are we lucky i'm not
actually sure about that it might be uh
ignorance is bliss you know so it might
be a little more of a headache but
alas here we are anyway today we are
doing an ask me
anything and all of the questions that i
am sourcing here and i got a couple
dozen of them i'm gonna get to as many
as possible uh all of the questions are
sourced
from reubenreport.com that is our locals
community and i know a whole bunch of
you have joined our numbers are blowing
up over there and i'm able to
communicate with you guys directly over
there
so you can check it out on the desktop
at rubinreport.com or you can download
our ios
or google play app just search reuben
report in either of those stores
and or you can download the locals app
and
stuff there's stuff out there on the
internet did you know you could put
things on your phone it's incredible
stuff
all right so let's just jump right into
it there's a ton of great questions
obviously most of them
are politically based i said to the
people you can ask me anything
i'd be happy to talk about sports or
video games or sneakers
or painting or music or anything maybe
i'll add a couple of my own questions in
because i got mostly political questions
but they're actually really great
questions and it's
and it's a pretty diverse set of
thoughts uh so i'll start with uh macrib
who says what do you think about a haley
crenshaw ticket in 2024
well let me be very very very very clear
about that i would vote for a haley
crenshaw ticket in a second like in an
absolute
millisecond i would vote for that ticket
and by the way i
i truly believe this that let's assume
for a second that trump wins and there's
some questions
later on about whether what happens if
he wins and what happens if he loses
if trump wins and we have four more
years
of the destruction of sort of the
democratic party and finally we're able
to get critical race theory out of
politics and social justice really takes
a hit
and and you see that the sort of
zeitgeist
is moving towards sort of more freedom
and enough of the political correctness
and all that
i think after eight years of trump trump
and the sort of
maga movement the thing behind trump
that was the great wrecking ball
i don't think that will be necessary
anymore and then what i think will
happen
is that you will get a truly diverse set
of republican candidates like never seen
before and by diverse
i mean the stupid immutable
characteristic stuff that the left loves
in that it'll be
it'll be black and white and latino and
gay and female and blah blah blah blah
maybe we can get one person to hold all
those things at once
um who would be the that would be the
best democratic candidate ever you give
him a lazy eye and a limp and it's like
you got you got 20 years of
running the country um but i really
think that after
eight years of trump the wrecking ball
that there will be a reset
that all of the reasons that you guys
watch this or you watch ben
shapiro or any of the sort of new voices
crowder like the
the younger right leaning thing that is
diverse in its set of ideas
that will be what comes after trump now
if trump loses
then i think it's completely i don't
know what happens to to the republicans
if trump loses i could see the
republicans either just going back to
the generic
romney republicans who sort of sound
middle of the road so they lose all the
time
or i could see actually the much scarier
thing which is we could start growing a
genuine far right in the country and and
that's why
calling trump far right this whole time
and a white supremacist and a neo-nazi
was so bad because he's not as he said
in the debate last night he doesn't care
about any of that stuff he likes
he likes success and he wants people to
be successful that that's what i believe
um and and if he was to lose you could
see some really bad elements being like
well even trump couldn't do it
so now let's just go all in and get a
real sort of far right party
here in america like they have in europe
so i i think the best way
forward if you if you care about
plurality of opinion if you care
about freedom at any level and liberty
and the rest of it is that trump wins
and then after trump and i actually
think he would be pretty good at passing
the baton
he you know that's what the apprentice
was right like that's what it was all
about the show the apprentice which by
the way
well before trump was running for office
i never watched any reality shows i did
not watch
any reality shows i never watched uh the
ozzy osbourne thing or
who wants to be a millionaire i didn't
watch any of that stuff or the jersey
shore
but i watched celebrity apprentice i
don't know why there were there was
something about it i think he'd be
pretty good at passing the baton and
going oh now we can have a crop of
republicans
that are that don't have to be sort of
so bombastic that don't have to
fight the system as much we we did it
for eight years and now we can hand it
off to people who are
who are really well versed in the
constitution
and our laws who have incredibly
interesting rich diverse backgrounds
like nikki haley
like dan crenshaw and i think i think
that would be would be pretty sweet
um storm says how do you how does the
average person balance being well
informed
versus staying sane man that's the
million-dollar question right i mean i
write a little bit about this in
in chapter 10 of don't burn this book of
sort of how to say how to stay sane
in this information war or at in this
reality war
as i've been putting it because as i
said last night you know we've got the
political battle
we've got the cultural battle but really
they sit within the reality
war which is that everyone's catering
information to themselves and you can't
have a political battle or a cultural
battle with
when everybody has a different set of
information so staying sane in this
thing is really hard
there are a lot of people i know people
very well that i'm very close to that
are really struggling with this
i i struggle with it to some degree like
i have i try to tell you guys
what i think to the best of my ability
and i try to do it in an
honest and truthful way but is it
possible that sometimes
i'm misinformed about something sure
it's possible could it could a story be
changing as i'm talking about it sure
that could be happening
uh could some of my biases leak into
some of this stuff yeah and i by the way
i try to be honest about that and i'm
not sitting here pretending that i don't
have biases
but as to your question of being sane i
would say there are a few things you
could do
you know two of the things we do just
involve bedroom we have no tv in our
bedroom i believe the bedroom is for two
things you can probably figure out what
those things are
we have no tv and i don't bring my phone
into the bedroom you know the idea that
you can
have the last thing that you look at at
night be that black mirror and see all
the chaos and then you go to bed like
your brain is still
it's still running like endless speed
and and that you might wake up in the
middle of the night and look at it or in
the morning the first thing you do i can
open up twitter and and see a pink anime
genderless avatar tell me
you know that i'm a douchebag or
something like it's just it's just not
necessary so i think there are little
things you can do in your life to to
disconnect
um including those type of things and
then you know like there's some generic
stuff that i could tell you like
a little bit of exercise like find some
stuff that you really love watching i i
keep joking with everyone around here
and my staff that uh when i'm doing
cardio
we have a roku on that tv and if you
were to look at my youtube search
history it's like i got old episodes of
the transformers i got old basketball
games i got old gi joes
i got uh i watch a lot of like old
frankie valley concerts and tina turner
concerts
and i watch some old wwe wrestling and
it's like basically i'm doing things
that
i probably would have done back in 1987
but do some things that you enjoy that
that aren't political i would say that
that's a pretty good one
uh oh for this next question we're gonna
throw to some video
because uh simontech asks a really good
question
here and and i think when i talk about
the reality war
of how things happen and then if you
just see them you acknowledge it but if
you don't see it or if the media is
hiding it from you then you're living in
a different reality well this is a great
question
he says other than masks does biden
actually have a plan
because trump lists all sorts of
companies involved in everything going
on
and biden complains that trump isn't
doing enough and that masks will set you
free
okay before i say anything here we are
now going to throw to a video
this is of fouchy dr fauci right trust
the scientists we love
fauci fauci hates trump trump hates
fouchy
this is fouchy this is march 8th of this
year
right now in the united states people
should not be walking around
with masks you're sure of it because
people are listening
really no closely to this right now
people should not be white there's no
reason to be walking around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people think
that it is and often there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
well hot diggity dog fouchy
people should not be walking around
wearing masks right what else did he say
in there there's no reason to be walking
around wearing a mask
a mask is just a drop in the bucket
right
you see what's going on here people
these guys all change things
the the who the cdc over months change
things when the lockdowns were sold on
us what were we told
flatten the curve 15 days we're now
eight months
in i remember and find the videos of me
saying it back
in may back in june when they were
saying oh we're gonna in california
we're gonna lock you down until august
1st and i remember saying well
why the hell would we believe you of
course it's going to go on longer than
that
where are we now end of october it's
almost november people
this this has almost nothing to do with
the virus anymore that is not to
diminish the fact that some people get
sick and older people can die
but the vast majority of people survive
this thing i believe
you as an individual person should do
whatever you think is right and you
should
instruct your family and friends
accordingly but destroying
everything destroying the delhi near my
house having me wear a mask when when no
one's in any of the stores that i go to
or any of these things it's absolute
nonsense
i said it last night but i got my teeth
cleaned yesterday and i'm sitting at the
dentist's office i have to put on a mask
to be in the garage then i put in
i'm wearing the mask i'm in the elevator
i'm down the hallway i don't see another
human being
i get into the office they've got masks
they've got glas you know plexiglas in
front of them
i sit in the chair i take my mask off
the woman tells me to put the mask back
on while i'm literally alone in the room
and by the way i was getting my teeth
cleaned you know what they do with that
that's when you have to open your mouth
and they ah
yeah so it's like none of this makes any
sense but if you
think that as biden said we're gonna
it's gonna be a federal mandate we'll
keep the lockdowns going like if you
want to live in your
basement forever and i think joe kind of
does
if you want to live in your basement
forever then then follow what these
people want
but if you want to risk it if you want
to if you think life is about risk and
chance
and reward and and that you have to make
decisions for yourself
i mean just think about the average
think about someone who's
put their whole life into a small
business a little restaurant
a little shop whatever it might be that
their life is destroyed right now and is
their life really think about it is
their life destroyed
by the virus or the government and the
answer is the government
everybody that runs the store should be
able to make a decision that they want
if you want to have people
check their temperature when they walk
in then so be it but
this is we have we have crossed the
rubicon into crazy town people
uh okay uh this is thx he says should
trump have asked biden how he affords
his multiple homes being a public
servant for the past 47 years so
you know what's interesting about this
is he they sort of did go in that
direction right i mean trump for
for a good 10 12 minutes of this was
pushing on the ukraine stuff on the
china stuff how did hunter biden make
this money he's unqualified to do this
you know you are you what was it big
daddy are you are you papa
what was the phrase he was using for
biden are you the big man something like
that
uh meaning that are you getting the
kickbacks like this is a mafia operation
right like if you watch sopranos like
the captains
make a certain amount of money they got
to send it over to send their cut
over to over to tony in the in the
nondescript
uh white envelope um so he didn't
outright say
that although i think was it was it
yesterday or maybe even the day before
he said something about biden's big
house and biden does have a big house i
mean this is
a few of you asked questions that were
kind of similar to this this is where i
would say
you know maxine waters who is a
democratic congresswoman here in los
angeles for south central la which is a
seriously depressed economic place with
a lot of crime a lot of drug use all of
that stuff
primarily a black neighborhood that's
the district she's represented i think
she's been in government for about 44
years
she lives in hancock park in a 6 million
dollar mansion hancock park
uh is super expensive super elite uh
sort of adjacent to
two beverly hills and she's got a six
million dollar mansion she's been in
government for 44 years i'm not saying
she did illegal things
i'm not even necessarily saying she did
immoral things but it
it doesn't surprise me when these
government people do this
right of course they're going to use all
of their power like it's a messy
dirty game it's game of thrones and what
do i always tell you guys about game of
thrones last episode of game of thrones
stop right jump 20 seconds if you if you
haven't seen it yet
but the last the last scene in game of
thrones it's like five guys sitting
around a table
and they're all drinking but everyone
they know is dead
right like it's a messy game of power
and that's what politics is so i expect
corrupt people to be in this it's it's a
it's a corrupt system
power is going to corrupt that doesn't
mean they're all equally corrupt and i
would always vote for
somebody that would give me a little bit
more freedom not take away as much stuff
from me not promise me everything
you know that that's the thing once you
see through the the lies of the left
it's like why you know
you're putting in people who are just
promising to fix your life we're gonna
give you all of this stuff like
yeah joe you have joe biden okay you
didn't do anything for 47 years you were
vp you were senator
like all of these great ideas that you
have you just didn't get to them all of
these years
you're either totally inept or you're
just a liar
i mean that that just is it i actually
thought trump's best moment
last night was i ran because of you i
ran because of you
and that actually is true like if the
system wasn't so
corroded trump would have never run and
the system's corroded and enough people
saw
it so enough people voted for orange man
uh well that gets me to the next
question from burned which is do you
do you really believe almost all
politicians are corrupt let's say on a
national level i
would just add one thing which is i
don't think they're all
oh i sort of said this already i don't
think they're all equally corrupt and i
think there are good people i think
nikki haley is a good person i think
that dan crenshaw is a good person i
think that tulsi gabbard
a democrat i don't know for how much
longer i think she is a good person
um i think the the system sort of
corrupts you it and it makes you
and also politics is is a system of like
you know constant different pressures
to get things done and having to
negotiate with people you don't like and
the rest of it and in many ways
politicians have all sort of backed away
from the negotiating with people you
don't like now you just talk to your own
team so
it creates a situation that i think good
people
probably become less good and people say
to me all the time dave why don't you
run for something run for mayor of los
angeles run for governor of california
and it's like i don't think i don't
think i could make all of those
compromises although i can tell you this
if i ever ran for anything
my plan would be simple i can't fix your
life i want you to have as much money as
possible we're cutting all the budgets
and
uh you know we'll have a form letter on
my website but i'm not going to read it
like
that's it that's what i would run on i'm
i have nothing to do with your life
i don't like you i don't want to know
you good luck
and get out of my face okay um well this
is another sort of offshoot of that
uh this is from emmy who says how do we
convince rick grinnell to run for potus
is he bribeable with baked goods to your
knowledge
uh i've had rick over for a couple
couple dinner parties i'm trying to
think on his baked good
situation i believe he's a dessert eater
but we usually do like some kind of ice
cream situation
um rick grinnell for those of you who
don't know he's been on the show several
times
he is he worked for several presidents
as he was like a national security
adviser and worked for uh
uh john bolton at the u.n he then
was our ambassador to germany under the
trump administ
administration then for about a month
and a half he was the acting director of
national intelligence
now it's ratcliffe uh it's not it's not
rick anymore
uh he's now out campaigning campaigning
for trump rick is a is a really good guy
he happens to be gay big damn whoop now
you would think that someone that has
attained the level of success
that he has and being openly gay and
fighting for gay rights and being at the
u.n and fighting against all of the
anti-gay stuff
in so many of these countries you'd
think that uh you know
some of the the gay media or the lefty
media would call him a good guy but they
constantly try to try to destroy him um
i know him
him and his partner matt for years now
and and they're good people will he run
i would love to i tweeted
out every now and again i'm like rick
grinnell run for governor of california
please i've asked him privately i don't
know that it's going to happen but
but again that that goes to if you're a
decent person why would you
want to be part of the mess but i'll
give you the silver lining because i'm a
silver lining guy the silver lining
is that again after trump breaks the
thing if he wins again and breaks the
thing
well then the machine that has crushed
so many people and cancel culture and
fear
that will have dissipated in a way that
new good people will be allowed to get
in i mean i think we're seeing that with
someone like kim klasik
in in baltimore like maybe some new
interesting good people
will get in but i i still think there's
a lot of fear around it and it's and
it's warranted
uh falcon says did you see anything
strange about joe's eyes last night he
looked like he was on
meth huge pupils that took the blue out
of his eyes
uh i'm gonna go on the record here and
say that i don't think joe biden was on
meth because i know that the losers at
media matters watch all my videos and
they're just waiting for me to say that
joe biden was on meth
and now that i just said it in a
sentence where i was saying it didn't
happen that's the sentence that they can
clip the joe biden was on meth
but i'm not actually saying that um
god these people can you imagine it's
your job to sit and watch videos of
people you hate so you can try to
destroy them how you doing guys good
good to see you um so i don't think joe
biden was on meth do i think he was on
something i mean look they
shut him down they put a lid on the
campaign on monday so on monday tuesday
wednesday thursday until the debate he
was
m.i.a so is he sleeping that entire time
like are
they pumping him full of adderall or or
god knows what or crazy supplements or
something
does he in the two debates seem way more
coherent
than he does publicly yeah he does so i
don't know what that's about i don't
know what he's
writing down or or has pre-written maybe
or on the things in front of him like
i don't know about any of that stuff so
again that's just like kind of
conspiracy stuff
but he has seemed more uh more coherent
however there was a moment about an hour
in you know he looked at his watch at
one point and then there was like
two or three moments where he started
stumbling and you could just see him he
could just get back you know the roller
coaster is going and he's like falling
out and then he like kind of falls out
but then the roller coaster comes around
he gets back on that's sort of the way
his his train of thought seems to work
um but he didn't
he didn't falter he didn't have like a
major falter the
the ideas i don't like and it's kind of
depressing because once you see through
the lies
of the democrats then you just kind of
see it everywhere and how it all is just
like
meaningless it's just all meaningless
talk about how they can help you even
though they've never helped you before
um so i do not think joe biden was on
meth is he on something like are they
giving him something possibly could
trump be on something possibly
i mean trump the amount of stuff that he
knows that he you know all the companies
that he's working with to do this
all of the numbers that he knows and
what we did here and cut this and all
that like it's impressive so like
is everyone public hopped up on
something yeah maybe
um oh i like this question this is trav
he says do you think in the future
people will refer
to trump as a third-party candidate who
usurped the gop machine to make his run
that's really interesting and i'll take
a sip of coffee before i get to it
the reason i think it's interesting is
because it gets back to whether
trump wins the second term or not if he
loses the second term
if meaning if he loses in a few weeks
and the system that exists just sort of
recalibrates and and is stronger again
right the very thing trump was running
against if it destroys trump that
machinery whatever that is will be way
stronger
than it was before trump that that's
very scary to me i think it's probably
scary to you
um and i by the way i know a lot of
people public people who privately
support trump but they're
not doing it because they're afraid if
he loses that the system will destroy
them i mean
i i just can't live that way maybe i'm
an idiot i don't know um
but i think if trump loses then the the
lincoln project
people and whatever the future of the
marginalized basically democratic party
that the republican party will be this
neutered pathetic
flaccid group of people they will try to
destroy any evidence that trump ever
existed that anything good ever happened
that he got rid of regulation that he
helped cause peace in the middle east i
just saw literally a minute before we
started this
that sudan just signed a deal with
israel so now there's the uae qatar
and this and sudan on top of egypt and
jordan which did it obviously years ago
and now they're saying five more
countries possibly in the next week
including saudi arabia you know what's
funny about this
was foreign policy mentioned once except
for russia
and ukraine and china was actual foreign
policy name
mentioned once in the debates the answer
is no trump needed to mention it last
night he needed to be like could we
just stop for just a sec remember that
piece in the middle east thing that
everybody wanted hey
yeah so i think he did miss a little
opportunity there but i mean if if they
get five more countries on board this
week
i mean it's it's monumental isn't even
the word
um but you know already this morning i
saw chris hayes on msnbc that little
dork uh who basically was like oh you
know these are just like fake peace
deals
you know something to that effect like
oh these this is jared kushner's thing
these
these nothing peace deals oh the nothing
peace deals that nobody could do
i know nobody could do them for the last
60 years but they're nothing now because
because of orange man but so if trump
loses i could see the machine just
trying to spit out and destroy everyone
that had anything to do with trump um
in which case they'll view him yeah the
legacy will be he was never a republican
he was never a conservative
he was just this evil insurgent force if
he wins i actually think you
you kick out or you neuter the the
ineffective
people of the past that would be a i
think a much
much better future all right oh look at
this i'm getting a telemarketer calling
me right now my phone
number uh somehow got to these i got to
every democratic list
prop this help this guy we're going to
stop racism
all day long i need a new phone number
i'm going to do that later today
actually
uh okay real quick um i'm going to skip
that one because i've sort of done that
then about a drug cocktail that
biden might be on again i don't think he
was on meth that was that was kelvin
uh jacob i think i got to your question
sort of about the alternative realities
in the reality war
oh and here's a perfect one to end on
because i've been focusing more on
on the gop and the right uh forrest says
what do you think will happen to the
democratic party if biden loses
will they continue to exist or would the
entire party implode
if so do you think that would create
room for a new party
i like this question and it's the
perfect it's the perfect place to end
um what i think well first off that's
what i want to happen
obviously right the current democratic
party
that that is either radically left and
using biden as the host as they
he's he's just the body with the alien
inside that's going to burst out of his
stomach a bloody
monstrosity shaped as aoc is going to
burst through the biden thing once
once he's on board if he wins biden
cannot stop it biden will not be leading
this thing it's all very obvious we all
know it
it's just the truth okay but joe biden
does not stand for anything if joe biden
stood for anything then he would have
accomplished anything but he's running
away from all his accomplishments too
right because he was part of what now
the left says is a systemically racist
country and blah blah blah okay
if trump wins then the great destruction
can happen and that's what needs to
happen the the democrats and the lefties
need to have their come to jesus moment
they need to have
their if you're an old school liberal
you have nothing in common with these
new guys stop pretending you should be
in the same party
aoc who's wrong about everything she
actually said that she got one thing
right a couple months ago
which is that she i think she said
something the effect of and this is
before biden was
was uh the contender she said that i
shouldn't be in the same party as biden
meaning
that these people have nothing to do
with each other the progressives just
used the the democratic party to get in
and usurp the power that's what they're
doing
right so if biden loses it's like well
finally the progressives they can just
either destroy
everybody else and then have their party
or and this is the much
less likely one that the good liberals
whoever's left after order 66 would come
in
and clean up the mess and get rid of
these people and let let bernie
start a third party a socialist party
with aoc and the squad and all of them
but they won't do it because those guys
don't want to create anything all
they're good at is ruining things they
want to destroy things that's why
in a weird way the progressives don't
really want to run anything because
they're not good at running things
they're good at destroying things right
so de blasio in new york city
he's destroyed new york city ask
virtually anyone that lives there find
me somebody
who thinks that there's something good
happening in new york city eric garcetti
in los angeles gavin newsom in san
francisco before when he was the mayor
before he was the governor now
progressives just destroy things they're
not good at building things
can somebody point me to one evidence
that a progressive came into a city
and cleaned it up and fixed homelessness
or got rid of drugs
or did something good with whole house
prices and homes and all of those things
it just doesn't happen
so i think the implosion of the
democratic party is necessary i think
that that hopefully will happen
and then you know again the silver
lining on this thing is that maybe a
a phoenix rises from the ashes maybe
after the implosion
there's just a feeling of
if there's something here between the
lefties and the liberals and if there's
anything good about any of these set of
ideas and i'm not sure that there is
anymore that maybe something rises out
of that and
a decent democrat exists and even if i
wouldn't support that person
it would be a much healthier situation
if we had a decent republican party and
a decent democratic party so that would
be the silver lining on everything that
would be the way i'd like to
i'd like to do it all right people uh
it's friday i will be on greg gutfeld's
show
tomorrow night so you can catch me on
fox news i think that's 10 p.m eastern
7 p.m pacific and beyond that i'm just
going to try to cool it this weekend not
pay too much
attention to politics we got a couple
house projects i hope you are able to
get off the grid a little bit yourself
and enjoy yourselves and eat some good
food and
run around and get out there and live
your life because that's what it's all
about all right
see you guys